hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the anxious rapid
knockout we have a game that simply
keeps on giving it his young shift of
Duda with the white pieces against
Magnus Carlsen and this is their second
game of the match first game ended in a
draw but this one I mean it's just a
spectacular one you guys will enjoy it
uh so much is happening in it uh so
let's dive straight into it uh do that
with the white pieces opens with D4 we
have Knight to F6 by Magnus C4 we have
G6 and not Knight the C3 we have Bishop
to G7 the king's Indian defense is on
the board and now Pawn to E4 we have
Pawn to D6 and H3 now so this has all
been played before nothing new here
Knight b37 Bishop to E3 and now Pawn to
E5 and again it's a fairly standard
position where white almost exclusively
advances the pawn to D5 and grabs more
space in the center however here Duda
plays Knight the F3 and now it's uh well
very very a a slippery territory there
are only a handful of games where this
was played as it allows black to
actually capture on D4 witches Black's
original idea so okay Magnus says all
right show me show me what's Happening
Here e captures on D4 Knight captures on
D4 and now here we have Castles by
Magnus uh we have Pawn to G4 by Duda
saying that okay he might be interested
in advancing to G5 at some point Rook to
E8 and now we have Bishop to G2 by
adding a Defender as a with Rook to Y8
there was a threat of actually winning
the E4 Pawn so Knight to C5 Magnus says
alright what are we doing about the E4
pawn and Duda says not all that much
Queen to C2 and it is not as of move 11
that we have a completely new game so
the pawn is defended but not really
because Magnus just captures it not
Knight F captures an E4 and what's the
idea behind the capture well the white
king is in the center of the board and
you will not be able to just keep it
there forever so Knight captures an E4
we have Knight captures an E4 Bishop
captures on e4 and now Queen to E7
putting pressure on the bishop here and
even though Duda is for the moment upper
Knight you will not be able to keep that
extra piece so here Pawn to F3 and now
just C6 you will at some point Advance
the pawn to D5 or to F5 and you will
force do that to give back one of the
Bishops as uh there are two Bishops in
front of the white king that's still in
the center of the board so here Queen to
B3 by Duda and now Pawn to F5 by Magnus
we have G captures on F5 G captures on
F5 and now if the bishop moves of course
Queen captures an E3 comes with check
and Magnus sold all of his problems but
the Duda shows what he really prepared
he just castles Queen side here and okay
like we said he had to give back the
piece otherwise he would just get
crushed so F captures an E4 and now Rook
H to G1 magnus's king size completely
busted so it makes sense to attack the
black king as soon as possible King the
h8 unpinning as you don't want something
like Knight moves and then Bishop comes
to this diagonal with the King still
being on G8 but now do that just goes
straight for the kill Rook captures on
G7 and this is basically the only point
of the attack where Magnus has a chance
of Defending but it's so brutal that I'm
gonna have to show it to you Magnus
missed it uh you you have to play Queen
captures on G7 but it makes no sense
because why would you put the king and
the Queen on this diagonal but sometimes
just just works that way now do that
with play Knight captures and C6 move
the Knight with Tempo just go for Bishop
to D4 you just capture it you allow
Bishop to D4 now you play Rook to E5
yeah you would happily now give back
some material Now Pawn to F4 preparing
to claim The Rook and now Queen to H6
spinning the pawn as the king is on on
C1 so here Queen to E3 unpinning now
again threatening to pick up the rook
and now you played Bishop captures on H3
and that's how you have to play it let's
say Rook to H1 now Rook the f8 you have
completed your development and now after
you finally give back that Rook now just
Queen captures an E5 Bishop captures in
something like Rook to F3 and there is
counter plane and on both ends nothing
really spectacular happening here it's
still a position you have to play but um
all in all you you have defended well
however Magnus played King captures on
G7 and now uh this simply will not do do
the place Rook to G1 with check and now
uh whatever you play is insufficient if
you go King to h8 to just Knight
captures on C6 it comes with Tempo
attacks the queen and that's pretty much
it but captures Bishop D4 check the King
has no squares you have to give up the
queen so Magnus plays King to have 7 it
is the only move to continue the game we
have Pawn to C5 now opening up a
discovery and now uh how do you defend
this look at this the bishop to E6 uh
Knight captures on E6 Queen captures
Queen capture Sun B7 and after Queen E7
just Queen captures and C6 and yes
you're up the exchange but your king
will not survive on F7 there are too
many too many threats lurking in the
position you can open up the f file you
can go after the the king this way the I
mean there's there's not much you can do
here so Magnus plays D5 it makes sense
let's just close the position and if
Duda does not have a move here then
Magnus has defended but Duda finds it
Knights the B5 and what's more do that
played it instantly as soon as Magnus
played D5 do not play the knights the B5
you you have to play this now you're
threatening Knights the D6 check with
this fork and it seems like you could
capture the Knight but you would not
have a great time if you did it if you
play Knight upon captures on B5
it's a brutal brutal line Queen captures
on D5 now Bishop to E6 and now okay you
could also try Queen cases but if you
try Queen to A6 then Queen to H5 with
the check King to E7 now Queen captures
on H7 would check the D6 square is
guarded King to d8 and now Bishop to G5
with the check but Rook to E7 Bishop
captures Queen captures and now Rook the
G8 with check forcing the king to move
back and now Rook G7 will pick up the
queen so back in that position you could
try Bishop to E6 but now it's uh it's a
very nice mate in three as now you've
taken away all of the squares that the
king can use to start running just Queen
H5 check King to f8 Rook or rather Queen
the H6 check King to F7 and queen to G7
will be Checkmate so that's what happens
if Magnus accepts this Knight which he
doesn't he plays Rook to d8 now he knows
the knights the D6 is coming and he
prepared a special gift for Duda so
Knights the D6 check Rook captures on
the succeed mattress we have Queen
characters on D6 and now F captures an e
for Duda playing with absolute engine
Precision opening of the f file for The
Rook uh Bishop to D7 there is no time
for anything else you have to develop
the bishop develop The Rook if you want
to stand the chance here so Rook to F1
with check and now King the E6 by Magnus
King to G8 is a bit more resilient but I
mean who can uh who who can uh play
every move in engine move uh so King to
E6 and now do the place Queen to C3
which pretty much uh drops all the
advantage but it's not easy to find what
to play here there are ideas like Queen
to D1 but uh to give you an example of a
Brute Force variation Pawn to E5 this is
all beautiful just threatening Rook to
F6 check to pick up the queen so you
have to grab the pawn and after Queen
captures an E5 now you play Bishop to D2
now you're threatening Rook to E1 to win
the queen and after the queen moves now
you play Queen to F3 so so uh what what
can you play here Queen to C4 check
doesn't really matter You're Gonna Play
Bishop to C3 now you can start running
now Queen G3 check and after King C5 now
something like Rook to F4 and those are
pretty much all forced moves that you
have to play in order in order to
actually win this so now if the queen
moves you just get checkmated Bishop D4
checking the B5 Queen the B3 check King
the A5 Bishop to C3 check King to A6 and
Rook to A4 with check it's a very nasty
stuff but Duda missed it and he played
Queen to C3 instead of this E5 idea uh
now Magnus gets a nice Tempo to
introduce his Rook into the game Rook to
f8 we have e captures on D5 further
opening lines towards magnus's King C
characters on D5 and now Rook the E1
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries so King back to F7 we have
King the B1 not uh willing to see her
Rook to see it on the board and now
Bishop to F5 with check King the A1 and
now Rook the see it all of a sudden
Magnus is finding moves that are very
very unpleasant for Duda we have Queen
to D4 and now Rook the C4 attacking the
White Queen we have Queen to D1 and now
Rook to E4 with some ideas of Queen to
E6 and then you will really have um a
hard time of uh well moving this bishop
as well if everything just gets traded
uh then you're left in a position where
Magnus is up opponent he has a past um a
past D Pawn so here a queen to B3 by
dude that's still putting some pressure
with B6 and now Rook to F1 attacking the
bishop so King to E6 defending the
bishop and now the situation on the
clock is completely crazy dude that has
some 30 seconds on the clock Magnus two
and a half minutes with Bishop to D2 and
now Queen to H2 by Magnus putting
pressure on the bishop also putting
pressure on the H3 pawn and now just
Queen to C3 and you don't want to allow
do that to start checking you uh for the
price of one Pawn so just Rook the C4 by
Magnus and now we have um uh Queen to if
three with check King the D7 and now
Rook captures an F5 and this is now
incredible after Rook captures on G5 it
is Magnus who is winning Queen to G5 is
a move you have to play here but from
root captures on F5 now look at this
queen to H1 check Bishop to E1 blocking
check and now Rook the E4 so of course
dude I saw all of this but he found the
Rook captures on D5 and now Magnus has
to play a move uh that
um well is is maybe uh not uh what you
would think you have to play King the C6
here and now after King the C6 uh what
do you play the the queen has to move
and basically the only move you have is
Queen captures an E4 Queen captures and
Rook D1 and Magnus would have this
position queen against a rook and Bishop
and whether you can win this or not it's
up to you but you are much better or
maybe even winning probably winning if
you're really good but Magnus played
King to E6 here and now he missed the
one a very very uh interesting move by
Duda so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find what Magnus missed
here while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able uh to
spot this uh congratulations on
realizing that yes the bishop on D1 will
fall but it's a matter of how you give
it up and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Queen to B3 this
is what Magnus missed and it would not
be possible had the king been on C6 and
now the problem is if you just play Rook
captures anyone with check there's Rook
to D1 a counter check if you will and
now after King to F5 you will just pick
up the The Rook here for example Queen
to C2 with checking to F4 Queen Toft you
would check in the real Kings that's
pretty much it whatever your players
really matter captures and you you might
even win the queen so Magnus finds
Contra play as he usually does Queen
captures on E1 and now Rook to D1 opens
up a discovery with check King the E7
and now okay you can't capture the queen
just yet if you capture the queen then
uh Duda just gets checkmated so you have
to be very careful so Queen to D5 by
Duda now uh very unpleasant uh
threatening all sorts of checks into the
black king we have Queen to E2 getting
the queen out of Harm's Way and now Rook
the C1 now trying to go for for sort of
a checkmating attack against the black
king Rook the E6 and now Queen the B7
with check we have King to F6 and queen
characters on H7 do they even wastes a
move to win a pawn because if he's
unable to Checkmate to the black king
then this will turn into a into a pawn
race so here Pawn to A5 as the A7 Pawn
is hanging as well and now Pawn to A3
Duda gets rid of back rank weaknesses
and now he will be able to lift that
Rook off of the C1 Square so here King
E5 by Magnus Queen to G7 check King to
D5 we have Queen to D7 check and came to
E5 so Magnus uh has to defend uh the
question is how can I do the push for
the win here Rook to D1 King to F6 now
comes Queen to D4 with check we have
King to F7 and now Rook the G1 trying to
get some Rook to G7 action here here so
Queen to E5 blocking the Queens reached
the G7 square and now Queen to D7 check
we have Rook to E7 and now Rook the F1
check King to G6 and now Queen to D3
with check we have King to H6 and now
Rook to G1 threatening mate in one so
Rook the E6 defending against this and
now Queen to D2 check we have Queen to
E3 blocking Magnus would happily take
this into a rook and pawn end game where
he will fight against White's extra Pawn
now Queen to G2 again
putting pressure on the black king So
now Queen the E5 guarding this where the
Rook covers this Square the queen covers
this Square so you cannot deliver some
sort of a nasty Checkmate Queen to G4
and now Queen the F6 we have Ponte H4 uh
like we said at some point the pawn will
uh need to start marching forward and
now Rook the E5 by Magnus a very
interesting uh a very interesting option
here was Rook to E3 it comes with the
threat of Rook captures on A3 as the the
B Pawn is pinned and then you would
really have to figure out what the play
of King to be one then you have Rook F3
and already you've improved your
position by quite a lot and if some like
win the G5 check uh it's uh for example
captures captures it's again I mean can
you play this can do the win this it's
probably a draw with perfect play but uh
you know uh that are definitely the the
best chance for Magnus but he played
Rook to E5 and now do that plays Rook to
D1 uh we have rooked F5 and now Queen to
C4 we have Pawn to B5 attacking the
queen and now Queen to C1 with check
King to H5 and now Queen to C7 uh with
some ideas of going Queen to H7 but
Magnus says you can do that pawn to B4
uh Rook to F1 was also an option just
trying to trade off trade off the Rooks
but now after Pawn to B4 which is pretty
much always great for you uh Queen to H7
with check and now you can't really
block with the queen because the Rook
hangs so Magnus plays King to G4 and now
we have Queen to G8 with check King to
H5 uh or rather
this line was not played just yet
um uh uh this is what would have
happened so if B4 dude actually played
A4 if if Queen to H7 check that's the
point uh now King to G4 and if Queen to
G8 with checking the H5 Rook to D7 and
now this actually would be winning for
Duda sorry about that as there is no
defense against Rook to H7 but it's um
uh you know uh not easy to spot this you
can give one check but doesn't matter
after King day two the queen is covering
this diagonal so okay after B4 upon the
A4 by Duda he does not want to open up
lines of attack towards the white king
and now we have Queen to F7 Magnus now
prevents uh Queen to H7 obviously Queen
captures an F7 Rook captures and now
Rook the D5 check dude that takes the
game into an end game this I mean this
whole game uh is is you know completely
a a deep dark Forest game even I got
lost in it just showing you the moves so
King captures an H4 and now King the A2
and this is extremely important if uh
yeah Duda does not play King Tay to hear
a few characters on A5 which you would
expect B3 and there is no defense
against Checkmate so dude of course
spots this he plays King day too and now
again he is objectively winning we have
rooked A7 by Magnus guarding the pawn
and now King the B3 and we have King to
G4 magnus's King is so far away King to
C4 with King to F for King to B5 and now
King the E4 for attacking The Rook here
so Rook the d8 and now Pawn to B3
getting that pawn away from the uh from
the white king and also hoping to at
some point pick up the B2 pawn and then
you already have a past B3 Pawn so here
uh Duda has to play Rook the B8 or Rook
the E8 check in order to still be
winning he plays a rook to C8 which does
not win him the game uh incredible as it
is Rook the B8 is winning for a very
specific reason uh that and now what can
uh what can Magnus play uh but you you
will uh see this better if I just show
you what happened if Rook the C8 now
Magnus uh can save the game but by going
Rook to H7 and now uh what do you play
here if if you just capture the Pawn
King captures on A5 and then Rook the H2
and then once the B2 Pawn uh has been
won then it is just a dead draw so uh
here uh interestingly if Rook the G7 is
played uh now again uh doesn't really
matter but uh if King captures that
that's a winning position but if Rook
the C3 for his example going after this
Pawn now you just play Rook back to A7
and you don't get to win the B2 Pawn but
you don't care if Rook after some B3
Rook B7 with check and now if King to C4
you just go Rook captures on B3 King
characters and King D4 and this position
is a known draw if King to C2 you just
block the king if B3 check you just go
up the board uh or even better here and
if King to C3 King to C5 you are
stopping B4 and this is a dead draw so
that's uh what would happen so after
Rook to C8 the move
and that allows magnets to draw with a
move like Rook to G7 Magnus played King
to D4 and this now again allows Duda to
win the game because he has the rook and
A7 to be used as a Tempo Gainer for the
white king which he goes for of course
King to B6 now attacks the rook and now
it's similar to what we've shown but
after Rook the H7 now do the plays Rook
the C3 he doesn't grab the pawn he goes
after the B Pawn and now after Rook to
hate King characters on A5 so Magnus
will not be winning this Pawn we have
rooked the B8 now Magnus defends it and
now King the A6 we have rooked the A8
with check King to B5 Rook the B8 with
check and King the A5 so Magnus still
for the moment defending that pawn on B3
King to D5 and now we have Rook the C7
uh we have King the D4 by Magnus and now
Rook the C6 we have King to D3 and now
Rook the C5 a lot animals played in
between as players are very low on time
here King to D2 and now Rook the B5
finally offering a trade but now of
course Rook the h8 the problem is if you
go Rook to A8 check King to B4 and now
King to C2 hoping to trade pawns uh Duda
will play King the A3 defend the pawn
and only then win this pawn and he will
just be up two connected past pawns so
after Rook the B5 Rook the a trade was
played by Magnus now King B4 we have
King to C2 King to A3 and now Rook the
H1 even trying to stir some trouble with
it will move like Rook A1 check but the
Duda just plays Rook the C5 with check
and he completely eliminates any and all
activity Magnus might have dreamed of
his King having so King the B1 and now
Rook the C3 so taking every precaution
possible before actually winning that B3
Pawn uh and it was in this position on
move 88 that Magnus Carlsen resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here whatever you played the the pawn
will be one let's say Rook H2 Rook
captures on uh B3 now you have to
connect the past pawns and you just have
to push them the black king completely
out of the game uh of course it's now uh
well completely winning for Duda but
what a game Duda completely out playing
Magnus finding that beautiful
uh beautiful idea of of just going for
for Queen side castles here I mean
absolutely spectacular allowing Magnus
to win back at a piece like this and
then going for the exchange sacrifice
Magnus missing the queen captures on G7
move and then finding Rook G1 and then
just going C5 and then just Knight B5 I
mean dude have found it all uh he gave
Magnus a chance to bounce back but to
this like I said this game was one one
huge deep and dark Forest that where uh
anyone can get lost and in this
particular game it was Magnus who got
lost in it uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed that second the
game of their match we'll see what
happens will Magnus be able to to fight
back or will it be do that in the finals
uh we'll see what happens uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to Jimmy LeBlanc and I would
like to thank Anderson Vira torko
stanquist ravishing reptiles YouTube and
Trevor Terrace for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day